so so think about this guy this this
michigan uh state uh
uh on the state board of canvassers yeah
who
was no matter what was said to him
citing the law setting evidence he said
well you know i have no choice
one guy said if that's the case then why
are you here not a rubber stamp for the
governor who just
we can hand the files to him you don't
you exist for a reason in fact
they had the opportunity to vote like
they literally counted the vote
three to zero with one abstaining it's
like so you could have literally voted
no
but this guy wouldn't and it's really
simple why i've been saying this for
quite some time
so uh you're familiar with sagan avocado
right indeed i saw that whole thing just
happened recently
no i don't know what happened something
happened maybe i haven't met well anyway
he's got a uh a new podcast called the
lotus eaters by the way so shout out
sargon
but uh i use him as a really good
example because he is like the most
mild-mannered offensive guy you know
that like the the social media age
has wrought and here's here's the
example
if twitter started banning a bunch of
people
and a bunch of crazy stuff happened do
you think sargon of akkad is going to
lead a group of
liberalists men you know with fedoras
and beards down to
twitter hq with pitchforks and torches
to smash and destroy everything
no of course not no he's sitting in his
nice little fancy room with his british
accent you know giving arguments
if they started going after the left do
you think the left would show up with
pitchforks torches and bricks
no but i do have account the answer is
yes i'm sorry sorry yes they've done it
i absolutely literally have done it i'm
sorry i had a counterpoint in my head to
be an argumentative jerk about it
laura loomer she did show up down to
twitter
yes not exactly pitchfork but is anybody
scared of her she she handcuffed her her
hand to the door
yeah and and she got pressed for it it's
probably i mean honestly
she she is one of the best activists
or the best the right has yeah and you
don't gotta agree with her i think she
said ridiculously bombastic things and
offensive things and you don't gotta
agree the point i'm making is
she always knows how to dominate
headlines yeah and she does it in such a
way that's like nobody's getting hurt
handcuffing yourself to twitter's door
like that's just regular old
obedience and it worked yeah so here's
what happens this guy aaron
you know he's uh you know a sad
scared little man who you know he
shouldn't be in a leadership position
if you can't handle the the the heat you
know it's the sword of damocles you want
to sit in that chair the sword sits
above you how do you even get to that
spot is it just something out of
appointment has he voted in like
something
the problem is we don't have leaders
anymore we have very very few i should
say
and so what happens is here's a guy
sitting there and he sees what happens
when the democrat
state board when the two democrats said
we are going to certify
did republicans announce where their
children lived and threaten them
so where are you the answer is no no i
know where are you going with this
critique
that the left is violent
terroristic like antifa types i mean
these aren't even
these are like regular democrats in the
community saying your kids go to school
here
yeah no it's a perfectly normal thing on
the left to say all kinds of stuff like
that and they know that when they say
that
antifa is the is is the cudgel who will
show up and act and they'll say it's
it's what is it called stochastic
terrorism yeah
they know that they can say don't your
kids go to this school
and then they'll say now i can only no
now all i have to do is sit back and
wait for auntie for to show up
because they'll do it i don't got to
tell them so this guy's terrified
he's absolutely terrified the other guy
abstained he didn't even say no
these people are spineless so you have
aggressive angry violent deceitful
leftists
and you have scared conservatives saying
just please leave me alone
right and i agree with you the
ineffective
wimpy guys like that or leaders of any
kind shouldn't be there we need stronger
leaders we need masculine energy we need
all kinds of
new force however i'm i just want to
make sure i understand this
the left of those played dirty are you
suggesting the right should play
strong or play dirty too they got to be
smarter
they got to be so look you know i i play
i've grown up playing strategy games
and what the left is doing is aggro
their strategy is hard
hard and fast strike him hit him low hit
him fast
get it done the republicans got to play
control better
they have to understand you know exactly
what they're going to do
they're going to make threats they're
going to come for your family
you need to know their move before they
do it and so that like you know bruce
lee
move like water when they come at you
spin around flip it on them
turn it up turn the energy back on them
you did yes
that's exactly what you did yes they
came at you and they made you 10 times
stronger 100 times stronger yes
that was a mistake and counting that's
what more people on the right need to be
doing
so it's it's not about playing dirty
it's about
you know i'm reminded of this episode of
frasier you ever watch frasier i sure
did i watched cheers and then fraser all
right
so uh there's an episode where i guess
frazier is having a bad day
and he has his normal table at the
coffee shop and he's got his coffee sit
down
he goes up to grab some creamer or
something and a guy sits in his chair
and he gets angry and he says sir this
is my seat and the guy tells him to f
off so so frazier just says i'm having a
bad damn not having it picks the guy up
and throws him
so eventually this guy sues him knowing
he's like a radio host he had money
and uh you know fraser can't do anything
about it so
eventually they end up meeting back at
the coffee coffee shop and then
niles gets in his face and then you know
you know starts pressuring him and
insulting him and then the guy says back
off man and pokes his chest
and then now goes whoa and falls over
and slams onto the floor
and then he goes counter suit counter
suit and then the guy backs off
and says okay i give up the point so the
joke was
and he was like i didn't do anything
he's like well we all watched you touch
him
you know that's it you're gonna get sued
niles got the suit shut down by
playing the same game that the guy was
playing got it so i'm not saying
like definitely not republicans should
not be going out doing antifa stuff
anti-people shouldn't be doing that
either
but what do you do if you know the d.a
will cut these people loose
boom like that because they got they got
elected in the first place
well they have a whole infrastructure
you and i talked about this many times
and i take i take extra
special pleasure now in documenting the
legal defense fund folks
oh yeah when they're out there in the
protest copying down the officer's badge
numbers and giving out bail numbers and
helping people get out of jail as you
said
not being there to observe both parties
but actually there as an advocate for
antifa
yep they have a whole network that
encourages them they get out of jail
they're not prosecuted it's a it's a
whole system we don't have that system
because we adhere
to the system of the rule of law and we
expect that if you destroy property or
federal property you're going to go away
to federal prison
so what do you do if you're playing
monopoly yeah and the person across the
table
every so often you see them swipe 100
from the bank and you go dude i saw you
do that you'd be like
what are you talking about no i'm
talking about i'm i'm allowed i'm the
banker
eventually do you stop playing i mean
you're putting me in a tough spot
because i'm the kind of guy that would
either confront or just completely
ignored the table well you just you know
i like to
pick my moments of aggression like that
and sometimes it's just not worth it but
but the alternative here of just like
getting up and walking away from the
board game
that's easy i can do that i can be like
dude i want to hang out with you anymore
i'm not going to play this game anymore
i'm out and i just leave we we do not
have that luxury
no that's uh it it
that exists in the real world and that's
the scary that's the
hitting the ground moment that's what
i'm saying yeah we're at a point where
yeah we've seen the evidence there is so
much evidence of first irregularity
because fraud we got to figure out who
did it and
is it definitive so uh following matt
brainard of the voter integrity fund
he recently put out a database like like
screenshots of excel
of people all using the same commercial
address as their residential address
some of them even post offices
yeah so so the response to that was that
they were they were using their mailing
address as their residential address so
that could be
a mistake right but some of these
addresses were just like
one of them i think was uh uh like a
shopping mall or something
like okay and and the difference is they
say apartment on them
so if you're gonna if you're gonna use
the same address and then call it
apartment number
to make it seem like it's a real
residence that that's fraud that's
evidence of fraud outright
one of the things that he pointed out
that struck me was that in i think
wisconsin i believe
there is a particular clause that says
if you are indefinitely confined
you can get an absentee ballot and not
have to show id
and it's like some x 169 000 people and
definitely definitely can find
right in previous years it had been some
fro tiny
yeah of that in 2018 i think it was like
16 000. and and he specifically noted
that corona
was not an indefinite confinement so it
that's one area where you don't need to
use a id
so of course that's a perfect vector for
so
that is the best evidence so far afraid
in my opinion was that people put
bunk addresses if you take an address
for a you know dairy queen and then put
apartment number on it
yeah we know what you're doing that's
that's fraudulent some of them are even
the post office
well but the argument there is that well
you have like a po box yeah
so their mailing address was incorrectly
listed as the residential address
i see see that's nice i'm not saying
it's definitively true that's what what
happened
but you can explain it away right you
can't explain away
someone listing a a shopping mall as
their as their residence
right like and and and was like a
thousand of them all with the same
address going down
with unit number apartment number you
know just like different ways to qualify
like
this is actually it's not a residence so
there clearly
is evidence of fraud now it's not
definitive proof it could be very simple
at this one shopping mall
somebody has a mailbox or something like
that and then again confuse their
mailing address
someone pointed out that you actually
like in some instances you can put your
mailing address as your residence on
some form or something and maybe got
mixed up
but you can explain it but the point is
we have all of this evidence
and going back to the hitting the ground
moment the fact that republicans held a
hearing at a wyndham
means the split has happened right why
aren't they having that meeting in an
official government building
right because they're now operating
parallel to the government
don't say it tim why not beginning the
beginning of the shadow
uh well cnn ran a segment where this
deranged guy said trump's going to form
a shadow government
i wouldn't call it a shadow government
but i wouldn't be surprised if trump
says if you support me
and you believe me to be your president
i will be
leading a movement um he could yeah
and it could operate within the confines
of the law but it could have powerful
and massive impacts across the country
people have accused obama of running a
shadow government
shadow presidency this whole time living
but merely a mile away from the white
house
yeah colorama in washington dc near
besos
bezos who bought a museum dude he bought
a
museum and turned it into his private
residence in downtown washington
if we have to have hearings at wyndham
hotels because we we're not we can't
have them in actual legal buildings with
legitimate legal proceedings
then it shows you that people are no
longer
confident in one unified system the
government exists based on one thing
confidence
that people think in their minds the
machine exists and the machine will
churn along
you start to realize then when you see a
judge and pa
issue ridiculous rulings or you start to
hear the state canvas guy in michigan
repeatedly just say i can't do it even
though he got the law in front of him
saying he literally can
and it's like dude you're lying why are
you like you literally can the guy read
you the law three times
desperately trying to say i can't
shows you the laws become meaningless
for the past year we have seen antifa
get away with
uh smashing things up and destroying
things and burning things
black lives matter sin felonious assault
assault with a deadly weapon
murder and so let's not sugarcoat it
well but some the
the people the most violent people did
get arrested and get you know charged
in that regard but we had what thousands
of people across the country who were
arrested and released
immediately many hundreds in chicago
hundreds in new york and dallas fort
worth who had their charges dropped
misdemeanor charges so then what's the
point of the law
if these people can go out and smash
things and get away with it what's the
point of the law if anti-fuck can
literally
organize terroristic events on twitter
with
no repercussion and they've been doing
it non-stop for a year
at a certain point republicans gotta say
the law doesn't actually mean anything
because it doesn't get enforced
then they're going to show up to a
wyndham hotel to have their hearing on
voter fraud
because they're rallying among
themselves saying we know this is true
and it doesn't matter if the official
building or the democrats think it is or
isn't
we we so at a certain point there's not
necessarily a shadow government
but i've been saying this for quite some
time with a censorship they
are pushing to create parallel economies
by stripping people away of their
financial institutions
and communications so now we have
parallel social media growing faster
than ever parlov over 10 million users
now
you have like i mentioned hearing in a
hotel like an official proceeding it
looked like it was
like it was a senate hearing but they
were doing it in a hotel which is crazy
and you have cnn worried about trump
forming a shadow government
but there are people who say
legitimately trump won and we know it
and they're not
you you had uh rhodes of the oath
keepers say that
he believes trump supporters half the
country will not regard anything out of
obama's i'm sorry
anything out of biden's mouth as
legitimate so it's it's like the
fracture has happened
yeah we smack the ground boom it's done
yeah these parallel
uh circumstances economies information
markets
networks associations these are all
happening this is all part of the trend
of decentralization and streets of
strategic disconnection
instead of us all being in the same
thing with no borders and no boundaries
and totally connected to everyone
everywhere at all times
we are going to start retreating some of
it's deliberate in an offensive way from
the other side to silence us or separate
us from the mainstream or whatever the
case
but some of it is coming from our side
too some of it is just a natural
phenomenon at this point where
you want to direct a barrier you want to
have a wall between yourself and the
people you care about and the people
that you don't know and that you don't
have the same level of care for
who people who might have it out for you
and eventually we're going to have not
just parallel
financial systems or economies or labor
markets but
decentralized and just it's just sort of
all a big mix but they're all
connected in their own unique ways and
it really is the future of work it's the
future of communication of finance
where people are going to come together
and build their own networks
where they can live work and play and
this is you know this is not this sort
of a longer term vision thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you